[Applaudissements]
je suis venu vous parler de deux jeunes
filles de soeurs dont la vie a changé
grâce à la musique
yasmine et omayma qui ont aujourd'hui 13
et 15 ans habite un quartier prioritaire
de la ville dont je dirige le
conservatoire alors les quartiers
prioritaires ce sont des secteurs
urbains comme on les appelle en france
où les difficultés économiques et
sociales sont là où les fins de mois
sont difficiles mais où les personnes
sont aussi dignes et méritante
qu'ailleurs
mais dans ce quartier on s'inscrit peu
au conservatoire
d'abord parce que ça coûte un peu
d'argent même s'il y a des tarifications
social mais surtout parce qu'on n'ose
part parce que la musique le
conservatoire c'est pour les enfants des
autres ce n'est pas pour ses propres
enfants
alors la ville qui a fait de la culture
sa priorité numéro un a décidé que même
s'il ya beaucoup d'inscriptions est
toujours de plus en plus d'ailleurs au
conservatoire c'est aussi la musique qui
irait vers les jeunes tous les jeunes de
la crèche au lycée
et parmi de nombreux projets artistiques
et culturels
un partenariat a vu le jour avec une
grande institution musicale la
philharmonie de paris pour permettre à
une trentaine de jeunes de ce quartier
d'apprendre un instrument à travers la
pratique d'orchestre
des instruments leur ont été prêtés pour
yasmina au bois pour maïmat un basson
des instruments dont elle n'avait
d'ailleurs jamais entendu parler
auparavant
et des professeurs de musique sont venus
dans leur école après la classe deux
fois par semaine pour leur apprendre à
jouer de cet instrument mais surtout à
en jouer en groupe avec d'autres
et ce dispositif a duré environ trois
ans les jeunes filles ont progressé
elles ont pris confiance elles ont pris
plaisir elles ont même donné des
concerts dans la grande salle de la
philharmonie de paris
et aujourd'hui elles font partie d'un
orchestre symphonique d'une trentaine de
jeunes parce que d'autres villes sont à
ceux aussi associés à ce projet et
yasmine s'est inscrite au conservatoire
de la ville oumayma a été admise dans un
grand conservatoire parisien toutes les
deux sont passionnés par la musique et
elle rêve d'en faire leur profession
alors oui pour ces deux jeunes filles la
musique a vraiment changé leur vie
mais comment se fait-il que la musique
porte de telles émotions des patients
parfois des vocations même et puis d'un
autre côté comment se fait-il que
l'éducation musicale les conservatoires
les institutions qui étaient autrefois
réservé à quelques-uns s'ouvre
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus largement
et bien c'est une longue histoire qui
est en réalité aussi longue que
l'histoire de l'humanité
on a retrouvé des flûtes taillés dans
des ossements qui date de plus de 40
mille ans et les spécialistes pensent
aussi avoir retrouvé des fragments
d'instruments à percussion et pense que
les premiers hommes utilisé également
leur voix comme un instrument pour des
raisons sociales rituels ou de
divertissement
bien des siècles et même des millénaires
plus tard au vième siècle avant
jésus-christ en grèce pythagore dont on
connaît le célèbre théorème est bien
pythagore s'est aussi intéressé à la
musique et il est le premier à avoir
réalisé qu'il y avait un rapport entre
les nombres et les sons et plus
exactement la hauteur des sons et leurs
relations entre eux ce qu'on appelle les
intervalles
et pour les philosophe mathématicien
cette époque les sciences mais aussi les
arts et particulièrement la musique
constituer un moyen d'explorer le monde
de le comprendre de le représenter et
peut-être au-delà d'avoir accès aux
intentions divine
deux siècles plus tard toujours en grèce
plateau dans son ouvrage majeur la
république explique que dans la cité
idéale qui l'imaginent il faudrait que
l'éducation musicale soit obligatoire
pour tout le monde parce que dit-il la
musique rend les âmes bonne et juste
eh bien ces notions pythagoricienne
platonicienne vont perdurer pendant des
siècles jusqu'au moyen âge et à la
charnière de l'antiquité et du moyen âge
philosophe romain et chrétiens cette
fois boys
écrira dans son ouvrage des institutions
et musica il y a selon lui trois sortes
de musique la musique du monde qu'on
appelle aussi l'harmonie des sphères qui
est une notion pythagoricienne c'est à
dire cet équilibre subtil mystérieux des
planètes qui tournent les unes au tour
des autres ce mystère de la nature
l'harmonie des sphères et puis dit il il
ya la musique humaine c'est-à-dire pour
lui l'harmonie entre le corps et
l'esprit
et puis finalement il y à la musique
instrumentale
c'est à dire ce qu'on appelle tout
simplement aujourd'hui la musique y est
là pour représenter la musique humaine
la musique du monde et pour être une
sorte d'imitation de la nature de
l'univers est là aussi être une fenêtre
sur le divin non plus les dieux païens
de l'antiquité mais son dieu chrétien à
lui beau s
est là aussi pendant des siècles ces
notions vont perdurer à côté bien sûr
d'autres formes d'autres formes
d'apprentissage est d'ailleurs à cette
époque dans l'enseignement général
il y à ce qu'on appellerait aujourd'hui
de modules d'apprentissage un premier
qui concerne des matières littéraires il
y en a trois on les appelle les trois
voies le trivium en latin c'est la
grammaire la rhétorique et la
dialectique
et puis le deuxième module ce sont les
matières scientifiques
alors il y à il y en a quatre c'est ce
que vous voyez derrière moi le
quadrivium il y à la géométrie il y à
l'arithmétique il y à l'astronomie oui
les sphères les planètes et la 4e
science c'est la musique qui est
considérée comme une science pour les
raisons que je viens de vous expliquer
d'exploration de compréhension du monde
et ces notions vont perdurer à nouveau
pendant des siècles à côté d'autres font
bien sûr d'apprentissage et heureusement
des formes populaires la transmission
orale du divertissement pour les simples
comme pour les puissants mais douze
siècles après boes chez legrand jean
sébastien bach on retrouvera à la fois
cette dimension scientifique de sa
musique indique une fugue de jean
sébastien bach c'est aussi complexe et
logique une équation et puis jean
sébastien bach lui-même vira de son
oeuvre qu'elle est entièrement dédié à
la gloire de dieu
voyez donc comment ces notions à travers
les siècles perdure mais les temps
changent
et depuis la renaissance qui place cette
fois d'une main au centre des
préoccupations jusqu au siècle des
lumières qui dans les milieux
artistiques et intellectuelles d'abord
mais avec les répercussions que l'on
connaît sur le plan politique et
historique le siècle des lumières qui
place la raison au dessus des croyances
et bien on va peu à peu oublié cette
dimension philosophique métaphysique
divine de la musique pour ne plus garder
que l'aspect de divertissement ou de
célébrations
mozart qui est sans doute le compositeur
classique le plus célèbre au monde
mozart n'était qu'un domestique au
service du plaisir du prince archevêque
de salzbourg et mozart consciente sont
de son propre génie en souffrira et
finira par partir et en partant de chez
ce prince archevêque colloredo
il commencera à émanciper avec lui le
statut de l'artiste et d'ailleurs de qui
se souvient tôt aujourd'hui de mozart ou
de colloredo
quelques années plus tard beethoven dire
à son mécène le prince liche 9 ce qui
des princes comme vous il y en aura
toujours des milliers mais il n'y a
qu'un seul beethoven et en disant cela
et au vin une place non plus le divin
non plus le cosmos non plus les sphères
non plus même les puissants les princes
où les rois au centre mais il place la
musique l'oeuvre d'art et son
compositeur son créateur au centre de
tout
et c'est d'ailleurs à cette époque qu'on
voit apparaître en europe de grandes
institutions musicales qu'on connaît
encore aujourd'hui le conservatoire de
paris et crée en 1795 il s'agit de
former une élite très performante
virtuose qui va être capable de composer
et d'interpréter des oeuvres toujours
plus complexes c'est un système
totalement pyramidale qui sélectionne
les meilleurs et qui élimine les autres
et c'est sur ce modèle pyramidal que va
se construire l'éducation musicale tout
au long du 19e siècle et durant une
bonne partie du 20e mais là aussi les
temps changent la démocratie s'installe
peu à peu en europe et même si ça n'a
pas un effet immédiat sur l'éducation
musicale sur les institutions aux voix
depuis une cinquantaine d'années et
encore plus depuis une à deux décennies
l'éducation musicale et les institutions
s'ouvrir beaucoup plus largement à de
nouvelles esthétiques et surtout un
nouveau public
est précisément
j'y vois trois raisons majeures il y en
a d'autres bien sûr mais la première
c'est que c'est une légitimes
aspirations des populations à accéder à
une éducation musicale de qualité et à
des institutions jusque là réservé à
quelques-uns la deuxième raison c'est
que là aussi depuis quelques décennies
des études scientifiques démontrent
toujours plus précisément l'impact très
positif de l'éducation de la musique non
seulement bien sûr sur les compétences
artistiques mais aussi sur le
développement du cerveau sur
l'apprentissage du langage sur le
développement psychomoteur sur
l'éducation des jeunes sur l'intégration
des personnes en situation de handicap
sur le lien social parce que quand on
fait de la musique ensemble
on s'écoute on se respecte on accepte la
différence de l'autre et même pour des
raisons de santé et de bien-être
et puis la troisième raison elle
concerne les politiques publiques et
bien sûr il est bien normal de vouloir
développer des institutions une
éducation musicale pour faire rayonner
sa ville sa région son pays mais face
aux difficultés croissantes que connaît
notre société les crises économiques et
sociales
l'individualisme le communautarisme la
violence est désormais le spectre du
terrorisme et de la guerre est bien de
plus en plus de responsables politiques
en europe se disent que bien sûr la
musique n'est pas la solution à tout
mais la musique et l'éducation musicale
constitue une partie importante de la
solution par le lien que cela permet
entre les individus et par le fait de
rssi menthe et une société qui par
ailleurs se fracture
alors la boucle est bouclée et on
comprend mieux
maintenant pourquoi la musique à la fois
porte de telles valeurs depuis si
longtemps depuis des millénaires et en
même temps pourquoi aujourd'hui c'est la
musique il va vers yasmine et oumayma
[Musique]
en réalité la musique nous accompagne
depuis l'aube de l'humanité
dans nos moments de joie dans nos
moments de peine de manière intime ou
collective elle porte des valeurs
spirituelles très forte on la montre est
la philosophie la métaphysique et en
même temps elle porte des valeurs
humaines extrêmement puissantes comme
cette merveilleuse musique du 23e
concerto pour piano de mozart
ce sont des valeurs qui nous permette à
la fois
d'exprimer de ressentir et de partager
des émotions
alors dans un monde qui connaît
de telles puissances négative et bien la
musique est là depuis toujours pour être
un pôle
fortement positif de paix d'harmonie et
c'est pourquoi je crois qu'il faut
toujours l'écouté la partager la
pratique est et la transmettre davantage
parce que si la musique peut changer nos
vies peut-être un jour pourra-t-elle
aussi sauver le monde
[Applaudissements]